o rico já tem uma pessoa que vai buscar
ele no colégio que o pai paga para ir
buscar ele no colégio se for em cidade
pequena é um mototaxi mototaxi pago por
mês 11:30 el tá na porta da escola para
pegar o menino e o do pobre olha aqui ó
ó ó aí ó ó fica com as perninhas bem
boazinha PR você voltar pra casa não aí
eles vão pra casa sol quente tudo
pequenininho segurando a bolsinha aqui e
eles vão em grupo e o grupo é a mesma
pessoa que brigaram na sala de aula meia
hora atrás o bom é isso ninguém guarda
recentimento só que o menino do pobre é
o seguinte ele volta para casa no sol
reclamando de tudo o sol quente 11:30
para meiodia rachando coitado mora uns 2
Km de casa ele anda nesses 2 Km no sol
suado cansado ele ainda arranja tempo e
disposição para tocar a campainha dos
outros e sair correndo mas menino é o
cão parece que é uma mensagem do pobre
por rico ai tu manda carrinho pegar o
fim na escola pô Vou tocar na tua
campanha e vou sair correndo falar da